une biotech est par contre la chance de
proposer également son public des
éparges anciens les ouvrages anciens
hérité de son ancêtre la bibliothèque
cologna est donc pas messieurs la
llorona on aa pu soirée est arrivé
jusqu'à nous un véritable trésor
une collection c est incomplète mais
rare ici il s'agit de l'album de route
grâce à lui on voyage en temps
grâce à lui on a d'innombrables
représentation de la réunion du 19e
c'est vrai que il est techniquement 2e
de représentation tel que la
lithographie et commencer à se rendre à
la réunion
mais grâce à roussin il a fait d'eux une
oeuvre de commande de représentation de
la réunion monumentale et grâce à lui on
a on peut voir ce que peut représenter
la réunion à cette époque là donc c'est
à dire dans à l'époque de de la
publication de son ouvrage donc à partir
des du milieu de dix neuvième jusqu'à
vers la femme 10 mondial ses collections
sont invités
rarissime pendant longtemps ont été
reproduites vers les années sont le
disent pas en 75 plus exactement par un
édit d'âge jane laffitte mais dit aux
jeunes la fée bat grâce à des biotech
est un conservateur passionnés qui ont
bien voulu reproduire donc des
exemplaires originaux donc le public a
commencé à redécouvrir au sein à partir
dans de cette première premières
impressions ensuite
donc il ya eu des essais de réimpression
plus ou moins réussies nés dans l'ue
notamment pour la deuxième édition par
océan éditions nous au niveau de la
bibliothèque départementale par le biais
de l'eee co2 teq historique de l'acier
indien
on a voulu diffuser largement ses
illustrations saisi ses lithographies
donc en les faisant numérisés et et en
les publiant sur le site du conseil
général du country historique de l'océan
indien
alors si vous pouvez pas venir nous voir
si vous habitez à 2000 watts irez vous
pouvez donc à partir de ce site et
aimait voyager dans le temps comme nous
nous faisons à travers ses photographies